- All right, y'all.
When I see something insanely
adorable on social media,
I know exactly who to share it with.
All of you.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat energetic music)
A lot of kids will ask their
moms and dads for a dog,
maybe a cat or a fish.
Well, one first grader has
something else in mind.
Madeline wants a unicorn, y'all.
(crowd exults)
It's incredible.
And just to be sure she
could keep one at home,
she wrote a letter
to the local animal control
asking for permission.
Lo and behold, she got official approval
from the county with a few caveats.
(Kelly chuckles)
Here are just a couple.
The unicorn is given regular access
to sunlight, moonbeams, and rainbows.
(crowd laughs)
Amazing.
Next, any sparkles or glitter used
on the unicorn must be
non-toxic and biodegradable
to ensure the unicorn's good health.
I love animal control.
Right now, we have Madeline
on the line right now
along with her momma, Leilani
and the LA County
Department of Animal Control
and Control Director, Marcia.
Y'all give it up.
(crowd claps)
- Hi!
- Oh my gosh!
Well, Leilani and Madeline,
how did the idea of a
pet unicorn come about?
This is incredible.
- Well, I've always wanted a
pet unicorn since I was three
because they're so magical and
they can grant magic wishes.
They can also produce their
own glitter and sparkles.
So, when me and my mom
were talking about pets,
I said, I wanted a pet unicorn.
So she said,
"Well, you're going to need some type
of permission for such a large animal."
- Exactly.
And Madeline said, "Okay."
And just walked on
upstairs, 20 minutes later.
She had gone into my stationary box,
wrote her own letter and came back down
and handed it to me and
asked me to mail it for her.
We never expected to hear
a response from LA County.
And when Marcia called, we
decided to keep it a secret
and surprise her on her birthday.
So on her seventh birthday,
we went to tour the animal care center
and we were able to see all
of the animals in the facility
and she was given permission
and granted the license
and the stuffed unicorn right here.
And we're just so incredibly
grateful and thankful
to LA County and Marcia and the team
and we were just really
appreciated their enthusiasm
and their creativity and thoughtfulness.
It's been such a special
moment for all of us.
- It's incredible.
(crowd claps)
Marcia, what did you think
when you got the letter?
- Well, we were really surprised,
but thought it was a wonderful request
and Madeline had put a
lot of thought into it.
We had never approved a
unicorn license before
but they're not a dangerous animal.
So, we didn't see any
reason why we couldn't.
And we set forth some requirements
for her to have a unicorn
and the word got out and
it was such a popular idea
that we got a lot of requests
from people around the country
to have unicorn licenses as well.
So now our foundation is
selling them for $25 donation
which will help the animals.
A person will get a
pre-approved unicorn license
and a tag and a stuffed unicorn animal.
(crowd claps)
- Aw, I love this.
So Madeline, you have a plan
to find your unicorn, right?
Y'all are traveling somewhere, right?
- Yes.
National Animal of Scotland is a unicorn.
My family is planning to
go to Scotland in 2024.
I'm going to start my search
in the magical forest of Scotland
because I heard the unicorns live there.
(crowd exults)
- I love that!
Well, thank you so much,
Madeline, Leilani and Marcia
good luck with the unicorn, y'all.
I'm liking your post right now.
(crowd clapping)
(crowd cheering)
And that's not all,
our season long partner
pilot pin makers of friction
to go to race bull pin of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show" want
to celebrate the lovers
of unicorns and magic.
So they're giving you a thousand dollars.
So that's $500,
(crowd cheering)
for magical unicorn fund
and $500 to care for her unicorn.
Y'all have a great 2023,
thank you, all our guest this hour,
Joel McHale, Danielle
Pinnock, Reginason Pastor
and Linda Saddles and Corey Ward.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
(crowd cheering drowns out speaker)